there were 30 of them were sent to
kamala's house and what has come of that
I don't know what is she
well usually what happens is they put
him back on a bus and then they take
them to like like another ice detention
center right but like this I think this
looks like either DC or imagine them
listening to Kamala Harris talk and then
they decide they want to go back to
their country they go she's the vice
president
she's like folks I'll tell you this
freedom is freeing for you for all
and thus in the way that I believe today
we can make a better Union strong and
that she walks back in what's she saying
here is she this was a word salad the
other day no I don't believe it
I'm barely working
what's she saying over here
that's correct
my mother used to she would give us she
didn't have a mother she would say
what's wrong with you young
just in the context
yeah
she's great I love I am I'm telling you
right now I can't explain to people how
big of a fan I've become of her as of
late
um I I I cannot explain this new
Alzheimer's
ant thing she's got like early stage
dementia and things she's got going on
where she's like you young people think
you fell out of a coconut tree but what
you actually are
is you're here and it's like the
craziest thing like I think at this
point that's what I would do because all
of these problems really are so
unsolvable I think maybe that's what I
would do if people are like what are we
gonna do about the Border I'm like my
mother used to say to me you think you
backed up into a cactus but that's your
ass talking you know people like what
are you what are these colloquialisms
these strange sayings
she's become [__] the guy from House
of Cards Uh Kevin Spacey who used to do
all those things my father used to say
back in Gaffney my father had a saying
back in Gaffney that's that's literally
what she's become